photographer and director patrick holick
has photographed some of the world's
most famous and influential celebrities
and artists of our time including clint
eastwood winona ryder radiohead pamela
anderson viggo mortensen paris hilton
mickey rooney sean p diddy combs and the
list goes on and on recently patrick
directed the film mercy
mercy is written and also stars scott
khan along with his father james kahn
wendy glenn troy garrity dylan mcdermott
erica christensen john boyd and more you
know mercy is a story of a bad boy
writer played by scott khan who creates
books on love but has really never
experienced a true relationship with a
woman other than one night stands and
brief hookups thank you again patrick
for joining us it's a pleasure to have
you in studio ah thanks for having me
you know we're very excited to have you
here in the studio patrick
to see more on patrick's work please
visit
patrickhole.com and that that's spelled
h-o-e-l-c-k so let's find out about your
beginnings where did you grow up and how
did you
begin your love with film um i grew up
in
uh
canoga park california as a little kid
and uh
i
i don't know i think film was just uh i
had a video camera and i used to always
make little films with it
and uh my love for it just came from
watching it uh you know it was uh
i guess it was just something to do when
you're in the san fernando valley there
wasn't a lot going on so we used to make
uh films with all my friends as an
outlet and something to do and keep
uh something interesting going on you
know
and did you have a support system that
encouraged your creativity
um
not necessarily i don't think there was
a lot of people that were you know
mostly mostly was like athletes and uh
in the beginning of like uh
rap and stuff like that so it wasn't
really a
support it was definitely not like it is
today but i did have a video camera that
was around and uh
and it was i was able to do anything
with it
you know you mentioned in a video
interview that i saw of you on youtube
that you know you started shooting music
videos when you were a teen i believe
yeah i was very young i uh i moved to
new york city when i was around 16 years
old and i had met a
gentleman
named kevin bray who was directing music
videos and working as a bartender at
this place called indochin
and he put me right on into uh art
direction
and the first thing i worked on was a
gangstar video sadly guru just passed
away this last couple weeks uh that was
my very first job in um in in rap
and um that led to uh directing music
videos pretty quickly because uh
the
the music was exploding in new york then
and and kevin became a bigger director
and i became his assistant director and
slowly but surely i was able to direct
when kevin went from twenty 20 000 jobs
to 100 000 jobs i was able to come in
and start at about 15 000 as a director
and then carry it up just like everyone
else had wow so it was pretty fast i
think i got to direct my first video
before my 17th birthday which was like a
miracle oh my gosh yeah unbelievable
it's amazing wow
and then you say in the the video
interview that your life kind of took a
different turn and unfortunately drugs
came into the picture yeah i wouldn't
say too unfortunately it was and it
wasn't immediate it was years and years
of uh
kind of living the dream i think it was
because i was so early
and i was this kid from los angeles and
especially being from the san fernando
valley what i quickly learned in new
york city was is to stop living in in
such a narrow view i immediately met
another guy named vincent gallo who
introduced me to a lot of huge painters
and my perception was getting so twisted
from time to time i would spend some of
the days with with this music explosion
some of the days with some of the most
prolific painters that ever lived and
then another part of my my life was
watching restaurant here this guy brian
and keith mcnally kind of run this this
other uh social circle in los angeles in
new york city so i i stopped being a kid
that knew everything and started being a
listener and i think that's too too when
i said you know what i've always been a
puritan uh i never drank i never smoked
weed i never did anything and i started
slowly it wasn't all sudden i was a drug
addict it was like a progression from
weed to
what became street heroin and it was
subtle and it just got faster and faster
and faster and i just think it was my
desire to try everything instead of be
this kid that had this you know when i
first got to new york city i was very
opinionated and very like a talker and
and and
by listening i stopped doing that and i
started experimenting i think it's when
i was just like kind of expanding my own
horizon and figuring things out so i
actually i
don't think of it as an immediate thing
and i don't see it so much as a negative
thing at the time you know but it did of
course go all the way
over a course of over 10 years to
another place for sure so it was just
part of your journey it was yeah yeah
and what kind of turned things around
for you i mean what kind of resparked
your interest in life because if you're
at that point a lot of it you just kind
of feel dead inside so what
um it became the first thing it does is
it gives you so much creative freedom i
was writing more screenplays i was doing
more action and then it's slowly
uh ironic because what it gives you it
starts taking and it takes a lot more it
starts
evaporating soul and passion and he
start started from writing maybe i wrote
a novel when i was like 19 and i was
doing a lot of drugs and i wrote it like
the wind and then you know slowly but
surely as the years go on you're writing
the 25 times on a piece of paper and
then i would start writing the
in paragraph form so it looked like
appeared like a paragraph but i had
nothing
and
the message started really subtle that
you can't live creatively and be a drug
addict so of course what i did then was
i started a screenplay about five guys
that moved to new york city that all had
um
their issues because we all kind of all
the boys that worked creatively like
came from different parts of the world
and it was a story i wrote about how we
all met in new york but anyway long
story short was uh i had a character
that had a lot of problems with drugs of
course so i was doing research for that
final
act of of addiction but it just became
really clear you can't have a and b
and that was the message that just kept
getting back in my head so
eventually i surrendered and i decided i
i need to get clean to live in my dreams
because
right now i'm homeless and i'm sleeping
in a park or on rooftops
and i've lost everything i've ever had
i've lost a you know i went all the way
to a whole missing section
where i was you know a homeless street
kid and that was clear you know it
finally became clear like you're not
you know doing this and you know you
have to get your together
so as we mentioned in the beginning you
know your photo credits are just i mean
they could take up two hours of this
show how did you
start photograph some of these people
and how did this come into play it it
became um i did really well in video and
then i uh then i started the drug thing
and then when i got clean when i came
out of rehab i went to uh
a company called dna which is david
naylor and associates and i had this
reel from new york city and he said oh
you know it's really good but it's dated
do you do you have anything new and i
said oh you know it was just coming out
of rehab and i actually worked at the
rehab for a while so i didn't have
anything current so i went off and i
started shooting stills of um
of the people i was buying drugs for and
from and uh street gang so i kind of
went back and documented
what was kind of very very real at the
time to me and very current against the
advice of a lot of people they were like
you don't want to go back there and i
said yeah i do but i have a camera i had
this like buffer between me and it
because everyone thought it would lead
to you know severe relapse to go hang
out with that social sector but um i
went back and i did stills of it and
then i had friends in bands like cypress
hill and um different bands like uh like
uh
i went on a
a tour which was like the old
coachella which was called lollapalooza
and i had friends who are road managers
so i started documenting bands and
street gangs and crowds because those
were the three things around me and i
shot them
on triax with a canon 81 a 35 millimeter
and i compiled a large
piece and edited it to like a dub reggae
song and brought it to dna and i said
here's something current that i did for
five months and i was able to get a
beanie man video off of this montage of
still images so it was just a tool to
get back to music video
as i went through music video
i had this epiphany that i was onset in
a video and i i was listening to led
zeppelin and i was doing a hip-hop song
so i thought there was something wrong
there i was blasting zeppelin and i'm
doing this like this really big
commercial hip-hop song and i thought to
myself i think we were in florida or new
york i thought when i go back to la i'm
going to bring what i know about
lighting
into
the feel of what i'm doing kind of
documentary photography and i'm going to
give this a shot and i'm going to get
back on the path to making a movie
so i was going to do a fade out of music
video and a push into stills
and
also develop film at the time so that
was the plan and
photo i always say is a pleasant
accident because it was and people
always kind of go oh you're a
photographer and
you know i met photography 11 years ago
it's the newest thing that i did and i
found it to be a less forceful
journey and a more creative outlet
because at the time music videos got
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
and at the height it was very influenced
by
management and product placement and it
wasn't the same game we used to be able
to write something insane on a piece of
paper and go direct it but that wasn't
the case in video at this point it was
more about where the ipod goes and what
car were featuring and it was just
became
unrecognizable work so i i went off to
still and i found that ability to be
able to uh shoot stills as i saw and um
and be creative and at the same time
there was a lot more it became more
lucrative when video fell stills didn't
and i was then my objective was to save
enough money to make my own film through
still photography
you know we're going to continue on this
path um i i'd like to just interject for
a moment because you know i'm finding it
very valuable to to kind of dive in and
and just discover the work ethic of
those that we have on our show
um you know how many hours do you put in
every day patrick and and where are you
spending most of your time these days
um
my day breakdown
a little bit my days are pretty weird i
have my own company so i started really
early i started about 7 30 in the
morning and i finished probably about 8
30 or 9 at night um
uh the one thing i've got with being
clean i'm almost like 16 years in june
sober is i'm actually really excited to
wake up in the morning and start it off
i start the day uh in basically uh
you know like everybody else probably
returning emails and phone calls and
then i get into like i keep a really
tight sheet of paper about uh objectives
and things that i want to do and like
films i want to develop and then i
i kind of divide my day into photography
film and and writing and as best as i
can and
i kind of create wild card days where i
catch up on on things that i miss say
monday for wednesday and you know that's
pretty much how i kind of do it from but
uh yeah just don't stop
um i i could just say that uh
the way i've always shot was what i got
from learning and beginning with street
gangs and such was to
to not interject and just do straight
point of view to let the person be the
person and not uh
change or you know it's coming off of
what i was saying with like marketing
and all this stuff though so the neat
thing was is to try try to find let the
person be who they are not an image or
misrepresentation of the person
basically that's what i brought to said
is like i always brought no ego and just
like let the person kind of and notice
things if they communicated with their
hands we would nuance their hands with
light or they were a person with their
eyes just to kind of put punctuation
into the person and who they truly are
or who i felt they were truly and try to
stay at it try to stay out of what i i
don't know
out of the way as much as possible and
capture them on that given day without
any you know
force right
yeah and what makes um a person easy to
shoot and on the flip side what makes
them difficult to shoot
um
i guess people uh
when you get to uh shoot some of these
entertainers like when you think of
someone like say ian mckellen comes to
mind
what makes him easy to shoot is that he
can
access an emotion or a feeling um in
seconds
so you could say uh be a 22 year old
handsome kid in london he could close
his eyes and open him up and that kid's
there even though he's a 60 something
year old man be a horrible nightmare you
know like the scariest guy in the world
and he can access it so that's pretty
easy especially when you work with
actors like that on that caliber you
know
um some people
um i remember a case where it wasn't so
easy with uh
the great uh um uh what's his name um
really wanted to have uh
an objective a purpose and a reason for
every every photograph every moment
every hand gesture so he wouldn't do
anything if it was uh staged or
artificial you know you wanted to go
into a deeper read of what that was and
that on that given day it was just a
really good old friend of his sitting
off a camera and having a conversation
with him but um i've been lucky to have
subjects that are um
are interesting and and are um they have
something you know even in just the the
common the common people are very
interesting too
i even like people that don't want to be
photographed because there's something
in that too i find that fun i remember i
think back in the 80s when i was a kid
reading an article that um paulina
porriskova the supermodel
wrote and she said you know i don't
really look like that i just know how to
pose my body and and pictures to kind of
give myself that
persona i mean you're dealing with
people that are public figures do you
ever encounter and you don't have to
name names of course but people that
there is an insecurity and and you kind
of have to bring out a confidence in
them
yeah that's happened um it's very
infrequent really it's um yeah because
our time together sometimes in in that
stage is very brief
um so everyone's kind of there to do
what they're there to do but um i
haven't had much of it i've been lucky i
think it's like i always kind of think
of it as like a i'm a janitor approach
where i have like this is how i show up
and i'm not
another presence i've had photographer
friends of mine that are like equal tier
to the celebrity and there's a different
dynamic me i feel like a worker and i'm
there to to capture this thing and i
feel like it creates
a safe place to play we don't play that
we just kind of create this thing have a
really nice conversation and they arrive
and we kind of that's like playing a
game of pool together and i i just think
that i don't know if it was
i i purposely tried to do this style it
just sort of became
a place that they felt safe in to to be
captured and that's why sometimes we get
a little
a glimpse of something i see in the eyes
like a little more soul than i've seen
say in their junket of images all of a
sudden i feel like wow we had like a
miracle and i felt like i saw it happen
where they kind of weren't playing um
the audience perception or some film and
in between these shots all sudden they
arrived and i got lucky and i shot it
you know you have photographed some of
the top celebrities in the world
from tom cruise clint eastwood you know
beyonce knows p diddy will ferrell kanye
west keith i mean it just goes on and on
um it really becomes a question of who
haven't you photographed who who would
you like to photograph that you haven't
had the opportunity to yet oh that's
interesting um i haven't really thought
about it uh i remember i always wanted
to shoot
for some reason i always wanted to shoot
ronald reagan he passed away i wanted to
shoot manson for some reason i always
had this thing i want to shoot this
crazy guy um there's so many people uh i
don't know i don't have the names uh but
uh
there's a lot of people i'd like to see
i was supposed to shoot obama a few
times in it and we didn't time out to do
it i was supposed to do him when he won
the presidency for time magazine and i i
was runner-up and i didn't get that
shoot that would have been a fun shoot
um i'd like to go back into probably
shooting people like bill gates and
steve jobs and and meet some people like
jamie diamond and some interesting
figures i just started shooting more
athletes which is fun
i just shot a pitcher that was throwing
like 110 mile an hour fastball six
inches from the lens and that was
exciting it made it new to me
um but i'd like to shoot some more um
more people like um say um
people like uh
jamie diamond and um and gates and these
guys and
kind of you know because you get these
times where you get to kind of meet a
person in a in a pretty nice way through
this this work
you know so for those of you listening
right now um let's let's get those
tweets out let's put that out into the
universe and let's make that happen for
patrick here yeah cause we send steve
down steve jobs in a few minutes
uh you know we have a lot of listeners
who are aspiring actors filmmakers
artists etc um whatever you gain from
working with the best of the best on
this intimate level that you have um you
know what what have you learned that you
can pass on to us i guess a degree of
professionalism and um you know courtesy
and
you never stop learning from great
people like uh say eastwood and these
people are just really class acts and
and are full of respect full of love a
lack of ego
uh you know it's just something to
always strive for i guess when you meet
some of the best of the best
they're just really professional and
hard workers and great people like i
remember people like beyonce for being
super professional super kind super
helpful in the process and you know she
would come outside where i was smoking
in the corner of the polaroid and and
look at the light with me she's very uh
the bigger the bigger the more
um together and like everyone's kind of
making a good project trying to make a
good end result and i really admire that
oppose as opposed to some people that
are just like disconnected they don't
arrive knowing
my work and i don't know you know it's
just
it just makes it a better day when
everyone's kind of trying to make
something as opposed to just being in a
routine and the bigger ones have always
showed me that they're there like you
know the like someone like cruz would
say i saw your website last night i
liked this i thought about this and
you're just so surprised that they did
research as opposed to
some maybe junior actor that's coming
out on nbc that doesn't know what day it
is who you are why he's there or or
she's there
um i guess you know
i i lean towards the other side where
you know you're there to work and make
something nice
yeah that was actually our next question
was about tom cruise
so that's amazing and we're curious with
someone you know on that caliber what
are the discussions like and and also
once someone like that's in the studio
how much is he bringing to the table and
how much of it is your own creative
process but tom it was interesting um i
was shooting katie katie holmes and he
uh surprisingly visited the studio when
they were newly dating
and i uh have a mutual friend named paul
anderson who made a film called magnolia
with him so he had a little bit of a
brief encounter before and he um he
didn't really bring anything he just
wanted to do a photograph of them for
their house of them um you know together
in a portrait so that was just kind of a
an added uh added feature of the day
um
he he you know tom if anyone probably
met he's
super energetic and um he's super
professional and and very nice and uh he
pays so much attention it's it's
actually kind of wild like i remember at
one point i gave him the camera to shoot
katie when we were lit and shut up
and how much he was excited by it
he's he's amazing he's really cool tom's
the kind of guy that uh my friend worked
a lot of film he comes early he leaves
late he learns everyone's name some
people say he's a strange guy and he saw
that in the media where it kind of got
really heightened and how the guy jumped
on a couch he's a weirdo
um but i think he's just uh i think
there's no accident that he's worked
with probably
30 of the best directors
uh if you look at his resume it's crazy
how many directors this kid has already
worked with i think more than anyone
i've seen if you read his imdb he's gone
across the chart with everyone wants
sick even kubrick
it's kind of weird i think it's a
professional you know when you're
deciding to make a feature like that i'm
sure you're like who do we want some
defiant person that's going to be found
in bars
or tom who's going to be here and know
the pa's mother's
maiden name wow
but he's very aware
and katie was sweet and very
experimental she was trying stuff and
having i think a lot more fun than just
letting it go and it was a good day
so with someone at that level um how
many people are you dealing with as far
as their kind of entourage that's always
different that's interesting you know uh
sometimes it's huge i find that the
smaller entertainer brings a lot and the
bigger sometimes comes alone in a
rent-a-car
yeah and and is ready like eastwood
rolled in alone
and he's very very simple
and um
you know it's kind of funny you see this
extraneous uh entourage with some of
these guys and then the older ones are
kind of like oh we don't we know we
don't need that and i know i look good
in this shirt and not that one i don't
really need
anyone to co-sign my outfit today and
that was my next question again yeah who
just said you're good wow
you just find that thing like someone
like that they've arrived into this
thing and they kind of know
what they're doing and what they're
doing it for and
it's an interesting dynamic but some
roll deep you know some roll uh very
shallow
interesting
i never know you know it's just fun to
watch sometimes it's always
an interesting place to be on the other
side of the camera because i've seen
them come in really big and furious and
i've seen those some of those go right
out the door and can't get a job it's a
very interesting dynamic to be able to
watch it from our side
and how long does it take for you to set
up your lighting
and how long will you spend shooting
someone like kanye west i mean i mean
these are busy people yeah it depends is
it like two hours in the route or like
it depends on the budget and the uh the
the amount of pages and the cover or not
but um in
in the old economy sometimes we were
able to get three or four hot sets which
means uh before entertainer gets there
you put an x on the ground and you make
it perfect and they walk a b c d and
they leave
um
nowadays um
say like two or three hot sets um you
would get off and um i'd say uh i have a
great team i've been working with for
about eight years and uh they're up with
uh
lighting setups in probably 35 minutes
if it's super super precious and
and delicate uh they could spend as much
as an hour and 10 minutes on one if the
time's permitted normally we get there
before the subject make it all perfect
make it like a walk through
and then sometimes you find it exciting
that the entertainer moves so fast
through it they're like let's do some
more i'm having fun which is like you
know and sometimes they really have to
go and sometimes you know
they uh they uh publicist they'll say oh
they gotta go to this place and they'll
go i do no i don't
i wanna stay and shoot you know like we
have a flight and they're like no i
don't
it's very interesting dynamic
interesting
you know and and when do you know you
have the photograph when you know like
you know okay this is the one i was
looking for um i guess it's just a
feeling um
and uh well digital now you got these
big monitors behind you so you see
things faster
needs to be more of a curiosity before
now there's like you know i have a
monitor where i could click through in a
few seconds and see see certain details
of it um
but uh
it's a feeling it sounds weird but it's
a feeling that you got it or not
you know we have a question coming in
from mr window films and his question is
um you know working so close with these
huge figures you know has it changed
your perception of them that's a great
question
i
i don't know i see people as people that
to me it doesn't matter if they want an
academy award or if they do a real trade
uh
and work in construction i think people
are great or they're not great people i
don't think it's a any difference if
what their day job is you know so to
speak it's
um i guess uh yeah no
you are listening to film courage we are
speaking with director patrick holick
whose film mercy features scott khan
wendy glenn troy garrity and james khan
so scott khan you've known for what 10
10 maybe more maybe like 12 to 13
yeah okay and had he been kind of
on you to to look at some of what he's
written yeah we've i've read and seen
his plays and seen his films and scott's
been uh really campaigning he knew that
i grew up with some some serious
filmmakers and that i was kind of
disenchanted with a couple projects that
i put together that fell apart due to
cast or budget i've been trying to put a
film together since i was probably 15.
and i've had weird courses whereas like
the music video became you know coming
in fast and i and i survived it and did
it and did new york city and and then
addiction and and just growing as a
human being interrupted it and then a
long course of still photography but i
always had these films and i always i
went to new york city with a screenplay
to make a film and then you know life
happened you know life as they say life
is something that's happened while
you're busy making plans
um that's what it was but um scott knew
this and scott knew that there was guys
that had been production assistance when
i was a music video director that had
gone on to to make huge films and make a
real impact so he was always kind of
campaigning for me to make a movie
which i love him for he was very much
like a you know just pushing and pushing
and pushing
and um he gave me mercy i uh i read it
and i thought it was the best screenplay
he written because i didn't identify to
some of the other stuff he had written i
felt this one was really good
and um
and so it began
and so from the point that you actually
read the mercy screenplay and how long
was that until you actually had the
first day of shooting
huh from the day of reading it to the
first day of shooting it went relatively
quick what happened was is somebody said
hey we'll put 250 000 up if you direct
and starring mercy to scott
and um all he had to do at that point
was basically convince them that he i
was the right guy for the job and not he
is director
um
and basically uh i'd say the process
from reading it to making it was
three and a half months wow
because they were ready to go but uh
scott wanted to say i'm not directing
this and and get that across so you were
able to piece the money together through
there was a lot interesting things with
the money the money was supposed to be
this and supposed to be that and uh
it ended up coming in the final hours
when we were already 20 days into
pre-production in an office uh we had
someone fall out and someone come back
for all of it
yeah and it grew from 250. wow like
because you said that you had kind of
like projects were started and kind of
fell apart previously did you feel this
one yeah i mean i always felt this like
disenchanted feeling you know i was this
optimist and this dreamer and i used to
go in and figure it would be these guys
are saying what they mean and uh you
know here i am you know as a kid i was
at caa and we were putting the dream
cast together to this film like it's
golden
and then just like things happened and i
i became i remember i became
i'm one of the 50th dinners at the
chateau marmont with my heart broken
i went outside and i said you know what
i'm going to do is i'm going to make so
much money and still photography
said i'll finance my own movie that's it
i'm done and i'm gonna collect
celebrities phone numbers and get
everyone's cell phone number and call
them directly these are the two plans
and i started that course actually when
mercy came up i was just over it at that
that that moment i had that epiphany
where it's like if you want to get this
done
it's really in your own hands it's not
these uh middle middle middle middle men
and smoking mirrors and um you know
basically i stopped living in that
reality and i was like if we're going to
make a movie
we got to get the capital in the cast
and have a good material and go you know
the film is in some sense almost two
films in one because there's the
beginning where scott khan's characters
is kind of proud uh cocky overconfident
guy and then the second part where
things change
and
you know the first part shows you know
beautiful people and and good times and
interiors of restaurants
and then and then the second part is
different how did you approach
shooting the film the kind of the before
and after as the viewers will see
um
i guess
i wanted to uh make sure that that the
transition was really um
clear and um
and just i just kept playing it back in
my head and and writing my notes and my
subtext and all my kind of stuff for the
transitions between the characters and
just kept kind of visualizing what he
was like then and what he was like there
and
and um that's that's really it uh
how i
did that and for for you how is
filmmaking different than still
photography
um
well performance and and um
rolling of sound i guess your rolling
sound you're still getting a performance
in a still photograph but uh
i guess it's just a continuation of a
scene and then you know motion
there are similarities and there's sep
differences i don't know to the true
separation of uh
the two difference to me i think it's
all creating something whether it be
a still photograph or a film you know or
it just they feel very similar in a
sense i guess the only thing different
is that sound is rolling and performance
is organically happening and you're
documenting every second of that um you
know you're directing scott khan and his
father james khan um in this movie um
they were also in a movie entitled a boy
called hate which was way back in 1995
um but i i don't know if they
necessarily had scenes together you know
and and mercy they have some real um
heavy duty scenes together what was it
like directing these two this father-son
team together in mercy um did you offer
any direction um or was it kind of like
more like sitting back and just letting
them do their thing um no i definitely
got to have
uh conversations with both of them i
think in the beginning
uh
they
saw the material differently um i
remember that james was concerned with
the fact that he was such an unlikable
father
um and uh
scott had his vision of the scene so it
became a time where um
i would have really really good time on
the side with both of them
and communicate it and then we would we
would actually do it i got lucky enough
to uh do a run through at uh james's
house about uh
three weeks before we started primary
shooting for mercy and to kind of see
what was going to happen with it i know
both of them
talk about how
intense and uncomfortable and you know
james wanted to make sure he did really
well because it's scott's you know
something scott wrote and and vice versa
it was i think it was really intense for
them and it was intense for me uh but
they were just really great it just
really
they did something happened and and when
we started rolling the first take of it
i remember that was
it just felt right it just felt like oh
this is going right and i'm really happy
that this is
this is happening right now i remember
seeing like that kind of there was a
silence in the room and the camera
rolled and that scene started and it
went really well i think they were both
really um hard on themselves and that
you know this that moment wasn't as easy
safe for them as it was for someone like
me that's observing it
you know their family and it's his dad
and his intent yeah you know i remember
reading somewhere that you know they
you know scott said that you know they
have a totally different relationship in
real life so to try to act that out you
know and be authentic and be honest and
be real yeah it was very challenging for
them yes james said something to me said
you know what you always want his
unpredictability and a performer
otherwise you don't have and uh
he's a very unpredictable and a good way
guy
so that's a good way to put it yeah you
know i mean this film has scott khan it
has wendy glenn troy garrity erica
christensen um dylan mcdermott um james
khan um can you tell us about the
challenges that you face getting mercy
and you know it's theatrical run um
well yeah well the first challenge was
we i think we thought we were going to
sundance really fast and like in a
bullet and that wasn't the case they
didn't didn't have any interest in
having us at the festival
um and then um it was just kind of
kind of re-thinking um how it would play
and then just kind of a miracle in the
sense that we did okay in this berlin
film market we got some attention then
we got to be in cinevegas which is a
really good help and then ifc started
started seeing this film and lizzy
nastro who's over there
and she came and bought it and it
actually was a small world because we
had met through a really close friend in
new york city it was just all i don't
know it's so hard to say you know you
just kind of keep putting it out there
and then energy starts getting around it
and ironically ifc acquisitioned it over
a bunch of the ones that were in our
original goal which was sundance that
didn't get bought so go figure you know
i can't figure it out it's just kind of
wild um they were re they they
understood the film they were
campaigning about the film they weren't
um just kind of acquisitioning to put
something out they felt like the right
fit they were really they understood the
nuances and they understood the movie
and after knowing i knew that lizzie had
bought some harmony corrine films and
that i liked like mr lonely and i
thought she was the right girl for the
job i felt like she was she she
understood it and her team understood it
and they've there's courtney odd over
there and and they've all just been
really helpful and supportive
and not just taking my calls and just
blah blah blah you know you hear about
people buy a film and then you never
hear from them and you know this went
wrong that went wrong they haven't been
like that they've been checking in and
creating a lot of buzz and and push and
help and it's very nice
we have nathaniel j brown um nb set the
trends writing in a question he writes
as a model actor musician in raleigh
north carolina
what networking tips would you give for
someone
getting into the industry
into
which part of the industry that was a
lot of them
well he says he's a model an actor and a
musician so i you know he's giving you a
three there
um
you know from your from your experience
i mean what what could you recommend to
nathaniel in terms of really getting his
career going um i mean uh
i guess it's just to create awareness
around himself with his his abilities
like you know he does music to
make a video of you know so people could
start to see his dynamic
you know and and just work really hard i
mean it sounds corny but uh
all it is is really um
you know pushing and really trying
getting up and and doing the work
you know because i guess he's concerned
that he's he's living in raleigh north
carolina as opposed to new york city
with the internet and all that stuff
it's like it doesn't really matter i
mean what's the ban that just came out
of uh was it australia although the
brother and the sister what are they
called
this just blew up bigger they played
coachella and they did the best at
coachella this year everyone was
freaking out they're they're like new
zealand and they're doing hip-hop
i don't know what it's called you know
no i don't know but that's like it
doesn't really matter i mean these guys
came over and they took the us by storm
and um it just was uh started on the
internet absolutely but we've had that
question come up before where there are
some people that are adamant that say
you have to be in new york or l.a that's
an interesting dynamic in our new world
i don't know if that's like uh
if that's so true is it i don't know
what do you guys feel like
i feel with the internet's kind of
crazy world of immediate visual
gratification and information absolutely
you know you know i'm a big believer of
the power of the internet and just
you know like you said you know you want
you got to put in the effort you have to
put in the work yeah you put it up and
you show it and you try to get hits and
you spread it to the right blogs and you
know it either catches or it doesn't and
you make something else and
yeah it's interesting more the time you
put in than where i think but yeah you
know and technology is so cheap now you
know in terms of getting a camera you
know getting out filming something
shooting something recording something
you know if you're a musician um you
know just take advantage of the
resources in front of you
um you know i think too many people put
put hurdles in front of themselves um
yeah that's just roblox yeah it's
important to know that it's just it's
really not about all that stuff i used
to say all the time it's like
like to get out of your own way and like
get therapy for those kind of blocks
because i definitely had him as well
it's just there's nothing we can't do
there really isn't
you know i guess lastly i just want to
touch on um
you know you've had some great things
happen here with mercy um you know all
the challenges that you faced in
previous years getting a project off the
ground
there really seems to be some sort of
magical force
behind behind mercy getting made
um
you know i mean what was it was it scott
khan was it the fact that that he was
just on this and that he got behind it
and that he was also going to make it
happen what really
i think scott is like uh one of the best
executive producers and and um
passionate guys i know
and i really really admire his drive
scott as i'm like scott's kind of
aggressive and i'm kind of passive and
mellow so the team of us was a good good
thing
and i i really uh admire how how
aggressive scott is he he will not hear
no he keeps going down the street
whereas sometimes i'll say okay well
then you know this and they'll be like
no no no we're going we're go you know
so yeah a lot of it was his push
and his aggression and then it was uh
you know he also inspires me that way
too you know
i think we inspire each other for
different reasons we've been speaking
with patrick holick his movie mercy
featuring scott khan wendy glenn troy
garrity erica christensen dylan
mcdermott and james khan is in theaters
right now for more info please visit
ifcfilms.com and for more info on
patrick's work please visit
patrickholic.com and that's h-o-e-l-c-k
so patrick it's been great having you
with us in studio